Ms Leslie you showed up for et with a
snatched pony a regal hoop and a denim
on Ziggy for you you are working it from
every angle my queen thank you it has
been a huge year for you now your
co-hosting the Latin AMAs you're
performing tell me everything
yes I am so excited I'm so excited to be
a part of such a huge night yes it's a
special night too because we're we're
sending out a really big mattress to
message which is empowering women it's
been such a huge year for women and the
conversation we've been putting out
there so I'm excited about the message
we're gonna leave the audience with as
co-host and and and as performers as
well and it's really really cool for me
it's it's my first time co-hosting Latin
Amy's so I'm excited I want to get into
the female empowerment say in a minute
but first of all I want to know
obviously it's easy to approach you to
say Lesley well Lesley we want you to
perform on our award show but co-hosting
that's a really big deal
that's a big it's how did you get
approached to do that yeah so that came
after we we had like found out that
we're gonna perform yeah and so that was
really cool because initially as soon as
as soon as I think of hosting I think
okay different fits so I'm like yeah
wardrobe yes which is always fun for us
yeah and then I asked okay what are we
gonna be talking about what's the theme
of the show you know like what's the
vibe gonna be and so when they told me
about you know the female female
empowerment theme I was like wow this is
awesome
and that also is gonna be incorporated
in the fits that I'm gonna use and it's
just gonna be a really cool night in
terms of expression in different ways
it's a different format of award show
that I'm really really excited about and
I don't want to tell you guys everything
because it's it's we got a watch yeah
you got a watch but but I get to co-host
with some really really powerful women
in Latin music and music in general
Gloria Bailey Araceli Rosaline Sanchez
Becky hmm and so we're up there just
representing it for the women and also
we got a big responsibility because you
know some
the women up there are gonna be
performing as well yeah including Becky
as well and so it's gonna be a big night
it's a big night it's a big night so I
know that female empowerment as long as
I've known you it has been so important
to you to support other women to be a
voice for women talk to me about why
that message is so important to you
being a woman in this industry I think
it's it's necessary to take an advantage
of of the platform that opportunity to
uplift on the other women that may not
have as big of a platform measure as
you're gifted to have and so in my case
you know I get to use my music in a fun
way to uplift people but also it is a
responsibility you know it's a
responsibility to the people that are
looking to you to for them to be for you
to be sort of their voice and in Mike in
my case I started off in a very
male-dominated genre and in the tropical
genre bachata and and now in the urban
genre that that as well as
male-dominated has been for many years
so I think we have a huge opportunity in
the sense that we can now be the voice
for women that have been listening to
the genre for years but haven't heard a
female perspective and a lot of these
songs yeah as we would have liked to so
that's what I feel my responsibility is
and and hopefully as as time goes on I
could just keep being you know a part of
that female conversation so many young
girls look up to you and look to you for
hope or inspiration I think that they're
gonna get that after they see you on the
Latin AMAs what is the message that you
hope all the young women older women
women across the globe take away from
watching you on that very important
historic stage to not be afraid of the
impact of their voice I think that's an
important thing that we got to think
about as women today I think we've in
the past maybe might have underestimated
how much impact sharing the things that
we go through or what we think or our
idea
can have on people and today we're
seeing that that that's a whole other
story that we do have a lot of sway and
how people see the world and and the
many amazing things that we can conquer
together as women and as as people men
men alike then that you know support
women and support women's ideas also
deserve some merit so I think we're
gonna we're definitely going to be
celebrating that Thursday night but I
think it'll also be a call back to
action for young women older women to
feel important and to feel like their
voice matters even more so than they
already know but to feel like hey
somebody needs to hear what you gotta
say
[Music]
you're performing with Becky G C n Co
the deed and a remix T is what we can
expect from your performance ooh okay so
the performance is the very first time
we will be singing the song live
together all of you
yeah we just rehearsed for the very
first time yesterday and and it was
great because we're you know we're
friends we're buddies so we we kind of
start finding our groove and we are able
to communicate you know in a very easy
way but it's also nerve-wracking because
we all kind of like since it so many of
us yes it's seven of us so it's like
we're all trying to figure out like our
own groove amongst each other we're like
bro you're gonna move there so just are
you gonna do that again you're gonna
stand every time right so I don't just
bump it to you okay cool so you're like
a little squad yeah yeah we are but
we've we got it down we got it down and
there's a really cool finale that that
we prepared specifically for the show
that I think you guys are gonna like oh
and yeah I'm not gonna say anything more
but it'll be a nice special intimate
moment and and I think it's the first
time that's been done with I think so
many people in a collaboration live on
stage so your fashion is on a whole
nother level you serve looks every time
you step on a red carpet talk to me
about the fashion game that you are
gonna be working with the lightness yes
give me numbers how many wedges yes
let's changes girl lots of changes are
we gonna like minimum three where's that
we have so many changes we're like
fighting with time to see if we could do
like another one but like minimum three
okay and then sexy sparkly yes all sexy
classy message wise like very expressive
okay
a lot of the looks are gonna be I
wouldn't say theme based but they're
gonna say something okay well no when we
see yeah you'll see you'll see and then
there's a story there's a story behind
most of the looks so because I feel like
this this award show is a special award
show we're gonna be saying a lot
Thanks some things are just gonna be
like very like simple and like just a
statement just off of how simple they
are but but there's a story behind okay
most of the looks so guys do you is it
fair to say that this is a historic
moment I feel I feel like it is I feel
like it is I think it's also the first
time that in an award show we take a
moment like a whole award show to say
something really important so alright at
least like leave leave people with a
positive message about what's going on
in the world and conversations that are
happening so I think it's it is gonna be
a historic moment it is gonna be for me
as well because I'll be doing a lot of
things that I haven't done before lots
of first times yeah but but I think it's
gonna be a good night I was gonna ask
you you know I know that you're no
stranger to performing in front of
thousands upon thousands of people
hosting are there any different nerves
going into this 1,000% explain 1000%
they're different nerves because you
have to memorize you basically have to
memorize the whole script
yeah because god forbid the teleprompter
you gotta perform especially at the end
of the show yes towards the middle of
the show
not many mishaps happen but but but you
really want to open strong and you want
to end strong so you got to know what's
going on and what your co-host is about
to say so that you can go ahead and
follow through the teleprompter goes off
so that to me is like I'm really good at
memorizing stuff but but you know when
other people count on you to you know
make sure you get your mark yeah yeah
you want to make sure that you do things
right especially with the women that I'm
gonna have by my side they're like huge
so so yeah there are different nerves
it's but and then when you're doing it
all at the same on the same night yes
it's like a lot to think about
but I'll be present I'm gonna I'm
already mentally preparing and I think
it'll be okay
you